Two one. Boom. Miss Pat. We're live. What's up? How are Ya? Hey,
great to see you again. Glad to be back, man.
This studio is better than my house. Crap.
I'm gonna go home and tell moms we need to move in Joe Rogan studio.
There's not a lot of room for extra people. I know, I know. I know.
I was just fantasizing. Are you still in Indianapolis? Unfortunately.
You don't like it there. Hey, hell no. I like my fans,
but I'm black and you know as snow and snow and weave don't go together and you
know, I just don't like it.
It's the same or everybody at Applebee's and golden corral. I need culture,
culture coach Chicago. I'm cool. I want to go back to Atlanta. Atlanta.
That's where I want to be. I want to be in Atlanta. I love Atlanta. Yes man.
The food, the people. Oh, I just,
I want to walk out my door and smell Mexican, Indian, all type of spices.
I'll ask them. Male in my communities, duck shit and take ticket torches
and dry cause why women do the laundry? Dryer sheets.
I need some culture. I need to walk outside and see all types of people.
It isn't a weird how places just never develop a lot of culture.
Some places just the spots just never get any more. Interesting. Yeah,
it's just, it's so boring. Everybody go to church, nobody curse.
And when I come on my door and if I'm talking to a neighbor and I use
professional, oh my God, I said,
I'm not going to change my language because you decided to walk your dog today
and stop and talk to me and you've tried to talk to me and everybody picked up
big dog shit in my community and well from, hey,
that was fertilizer.
You see your name on a big old pile of dog crap in his hand. I'm like, dude, no,
no. I don't think it works as fertilizers. My dog pisses and shits on the lawn.
It just leaves these big old like yellow spots.
If you live long enough and it rains on and they just go into the grave.
That's true. They don't kill the gray. Don't kill the grass. I did the pistols.
The piss seems to kill the grass. Well, I don't know. We didn't have no grades.
Everybody walked through the grass. I just didn't care about it.
Loans until I bought came became a homeowner. Yeah. Homeowners care about lawns.
Homeowners care about a lot of crap. You have to, yeah,
I have a rental property in Atlanta. If I can get rid of that, I would never,
ever black people come up with some of the strangest things.
Why they ain't got they rent like as opposed to care. I tell them,
Bank of America don't care that your Mama that y'all do your grandchild had a
seizure. I need my rent money. Put a spoon in his mouth.
Tell him about secret. Yeah, I mean I've had some,
oh, I just gotta be so glad when I can get rid of this property.
So you own a place in Atlanta? Yes.
Would you live there at the place that you own? Hell No. No, no.
I wouldn't live there. I'm a little too boozy for that bullshit.
No, not too much to says I'm a little booze. You did a little backward,
but I rented out. I ran the nice place.
But you would live in Atlanta somewhere else? Oh yeah.
I want to go to Peachtree city. Kennesaw. Yeah. I want to live in Atlanta.
I love Atlanta. Why don't you make your way down there? What's,
what's holding you and, and then the Apple's healthcare jail. Health care.
My husband has a really good job that we paid nothing. His knee just went out.
His hands on going out and I can't pay for them. Types of things. What?
Damn. He tore his ACL running to the cafeteria at work. Oh yeah. I've done a,
I've done a tour. Both of them. You probably were exercising.
He was going to get food.
Don't watch this episode of Joe Rogan Baby. I'm sorry.
That's a rough one. Recover from it. Take six months.
He was six months and then he got a Coppertone in his hands.
So he's getting ready to have hand surgery type. What does he, uh,
he builds the Alison transmission for Alison for General Motors and she's
constantly moving things with his hands. So his hand is all a bitch.
My mom got that. That's a rough one. Well,
I'll never had a job where I did that much repetition. You know,
I sold drugs and far a few checks, but it wasn't an everyday thing.
I had to do so many checks. You'd have to forge for your carpal tunnel. Oh yeah.
A lot. So once you burned 32 you don't have any mo to burn.
You gotta wait to somebody steal the next book.
Plus I was really young back in the day. Yeah. Damn.
So that's what's keeping you in. Annapolis husband had a good job.
I needed a TV show so I can get some really good health care.
And when your podcast is launched now it is.
It's called the pat down the pat down. And I have my own song too. Oh yes.
We're talking about Ari. Yes.
Are Getting in trouble for putting other people's songs on his podcast and the
de monetizes podcast. Yeah, my nephew, Riverdale shout,
it made me my own little pat down son. Oh, nice. So yeah.
So somebody made a song for you that's, yeah, yeah.
I was just trying to do something different.
There's only 30 minutes of me talking crap about whatever's going on in my life.
You heard, you hear my kids in the background getting cussed out,
you hear the creditor calling me and my cohost is a little white boy named Chris
who don't know nothing about black America.
And then I got my friend who just ah, AH, he ready to go march if you,
if you need him to. So I got, I got this libertarian,
this crazy ass Democrat together and I'm down the middle and say, hey,
we can all get along. And they hated each other. They first,
how'd you get them together? Because they hated each other.
She did it on purpose. Yeah. My black friend thought Chris was racist.
I was like, no, I know racist. He's not racist. He just not eve to the fat.
And so I put it on the EAD. You've not tell him what I'm trying to say. Naive.
Oh, naive. Naive. Yeah. You gotta translate, you know, Adam and eve
trying to go with this. It was not easy, but it sounded like Adam and eve,
so it, he just didn't understand.
So we get them together and we have these conversation about race and uh,
we did an episode about abortion and Chris was like, he's really Christian.
And he was like, I was like,
do you believe a woman should have a right to have an abortion?
He just put a pattern all around. So Chris just say yes, a fucking no,
and finally said, I don't believe a woman should have an abortion. I said, well,
that's fine,
but this is my vagina and I can do what I want to do with if I want to stick
firecrackers crackers in my vagina and turn it into the 4th of July. Joe Rogan,
this is my vagina. As long as I don't get no vagina juice on you.
That make sense? Yeah. Atlanta's got a problem now with that. Right?
There's nothing. Georgia just passed a new abortion law.
I don't think it's passed yet, but she just canceled her shows. Yeah. Yeah.
She's canceled her shows in Atlanta because I think it passed.
I think that was the idea.
That's why she canceled it and I don't think it passed Joe because the TV people
haven't pulled out yet. Oh, there would if it passed. I think they would.
I really think they got money. I've got them in there because of tax money.
Yeah. And I think they are leaving. A lot of people lose their jobs.
I don't think they're going to leave.
I don't think the water should be telling us what to do with our bodies.
I don't think so either. Yeah. That means that you know,
I've been shot in the t that my want them messed up.
So that's like you trying to tell me I should get my TD fixed.
If I don't want my titty fix, it's my prerogative.
I shouldn't have to have my teddy fix. Right. Joe,
how do you feel about late term abortions? That's where people get scared. They,
I don't think, yeah, I don't think you should be killing,
don't have an abortion and no,
six and eight months now and I don't think it should be recreation either cause
I had an abortion just doing it for fun. Recreation.
I like how you translate. Oh, I've had a few friends.
What are you going to do today? I was thinking about riding a roller coaster,
but fuck it, I'll get an abortion.
I've had a few friends that had quite a few of boys since then.
I've had one myself. I mean my, in my situation,
I think everybody's situation is different. My situation, I was,
I already had my first baby at 14 my second child at 15 and it was by a married
man. Well I got pregnant by this mayor man again. And I just looked at myself,
I said, here I am 16 pregnant with my third child.
I cannot take care of the two hour gap. And you know,
it wasn't all of this stuff like what they tell you about birth control and safe
sex that wasn't going on in the eighties you know, people, Shit. And they,
those and talking wouldn't even talk about it.
Especially when you were a little kid. You know, when you're,
I'm 14 so I was a kid. So when I got pregnant with my third child,
I w I became a massive pain in minor in divorce.
My mom and I went and got an abortion because I knew he wasn't helping me with
the first two. That's so crazy.
So I take it on the first part because still to this day,
sometimes I'll be doing something and I'll just think about your story in the
scope.
Sound drugs as a teenager,
pregnant with two kids by the time you're 16 by mayor raised crazy in jail.
I mean I dropped out of school in eighth grade, you know, all of this stuff.
And I just say, I
said I don't want my kids to, and I'm like me. So I was like,
I can't keep having these babies and I,
and after that I got on birth control and I just prayed. I said, Lord,
I don't want no more kids by his bone and I never got pregnant so I got married.
Well that's good. Yeah. So now I have those two. You know,
I used to tell a bit about,
I got a set of Medicaid kids on the set of blue cross blue shield kids.
So I'll wait until they got older. And I mean, I got older and I, I became,
I started to learn about life. He taught me a lot.
And so I hit those last two and I tied my tunes. Very, very good move. Yeah,
I'm close enough. Four is more than, that's a good number. But you know, Joe,
I'm black so my family smoked crack so they keep giving me their kids.
So I had to tie my tubes to make room for the crack baby.
They keep coming in and not my house. I'm raising for rent now. Yeah,
I have my niece, my niece, um, my,
I picked up my niece like five years ago to help her out. Oh,
she had a baby that was two weeks old and I have this thing like, oh,
kids deserve off solid foundation because I didn't have one. So I picked,
this is my third set of kids I've raised and I'm just 47.
So I picked my niece up maybe two weeks old and she got three other kids.
I said, okay, I got this big house in Indianapolis, come live with me.
I got three, four extra bedroom. Well,
this bitch ran off and left me with them kids. Now I have a five or eight.
Yeah,
on a 10 and 11 year old and I've had these kids for six years and I literally
have not seen my niece in almost four years. No phone call,
no nothing. And you know, I'm trying to build a career.
So I have a daughter who, my whole, my, all my,
my kids who was at the house and they had to make a major sacrifice.
Like my daughter couldn't go off to college because she didn't want to leave my
husband with these four kids. So she went to college in Indianapolis,
but she stay, she went mostly from, you know, home.
My son couldn't go off to college because they at home helping raise the four
kids that I called my crack babies,
but at home raising my crack babies because you don't want to leave.
My husband would all afford these crack babies by they sales. So you know,
where's the mother? You want to hear some crazy,
the bitch blocked me on Facebook joke.
She won't even let me be afraid of Facebook. You taking care of her children?
Yeah. She blocked you on Facebook. Why don't you block you? Cause I kept saying,
I'm a kill you bitch.
I was ready to live my best life. I was like, Oh, I'm making some money.
Me and my husband go to Hawaii. You get naked float in the water,
Bam for crack babies. You can't do that when you can't.
You know how much you taking the how, why you call.
I can't take no crap with me. Oh my God,
I love that phrase. Yeah. So I mean it changed. It's changed everything.
And then you know my, when she left and she didn't even give me custody,
I had to go and hire this lawyer and go and get custody because she just ran off
and I asked the, you know, the welfare
system, it ended Annapolis. I said, can y'all just give me childcare?
Because childcare was going to be like $800 a week because my kids was in high
school when she left and they was like, no, we can't give you that,
but we will give you medicaid and $300 they get, they didn't,
they didn't give me shit. Jesus Christ. So I just,
I just made away my stuff and I said, you know what,
I've had this baby since she was two weeks old.
How do you drop a baby that you've had since she was two weeks old?
Your baby now? Yeah. You can't, I can't give up.
I love you so fucking crazy.
The mother blocked you. Oh No. Oh my God. No.
But we did make a secret account, right? Of a nice fine man like yourself,
Joe Rogan. Nice fine black man. And we, we, we friended her.
So she accepted a friend. So she don't know that that's us.
And she only Sneed your podcast so I can tell. So we follow her like that.
So she's on the other side of town getting high. Never hit me up.
Never talk about the kid. You know, I don't get a dime from nobody.
Nobody. And I don't ask for nothing. I mean I'm just at this point,
I'm thankful that I can even take care of these kids.
Cause my sister was on drugs and I took care of her keys.
My niece who's on drugs now,
I took care of them for 10 years with my husband and she's on drugs now.
The daughter is on drugs.
When my sister got them back and got them all on drugs like her, Jesus Christ.
So I made sure that these kids can't go back to that situation.
Now I call them my Bougie crack babies.
They won't even eat McDonald's only Chick-Filet
they're like, oh we don't eat McDonald's. We eat Chick-Filet. And I was like,
I remember when y'all ass in eat at all babies.
They give me great material, but it's not easy. But you didn't know.
You call them crack babies. No they don't.
They stop calling them kids crack crack baby.
They don't know. I call them crack.
Only American know that I call them crack babies,
but y'all can't call them crack babies. Call Mark. God, did they call your mom?
Uh, they do and his count on record.
So they just started calling me mom out of nowhere and I'm like,
don't come in fucking Mama my auntie. And, but then now just let them go. Oh,
it's beautiful. Well, they go to school and they see all the, you know,
I live in this white community. They see all these kids want a mom and Daddy.
And was like, well, why don't we have,
and they just started calling me mom and so were mom and my daughter who um,
she just graduated from college, but she, they got two moms and my dad,
my husband is their daddy. Yeah. I love the, well, thank you. Thank you.
That's a beautiful thing you're doing. It really is. Even though the ladies
in the black commune, she's a bitch. That's what she, those kids got lucky.
They got lucky. They really did. I took them on a Disney cruise last year,
Joe and Oh my God, they had the time or they lives and look at my Craig baby.
They don't know what, I don't say them from the crowd. Oh my God,
what'd you saved this from? And they're on a Disney cruise.
Craig baby on the Disney cruise with matching outfits.
But I love him. I mean, amazing that you're doing that. It really is. I mean,
I know it's hard, but it's amazing that you're doing that. Well, you know,
like I said earlier, every,
every child deserves a solid foundation to start off. Unfortunately for me,
I didn't have that solid foundation.
I didn't have nobody to step in my life and you know, snatch me from my mom.
But you know, whenever I see a child in need, especially a family member,
I always try to step in because I know,
I know when you don't have that solid foundation where you can end up in some
kids in or you know, fucked them even with a solid foundation.
But if you can give them a good start, at least give them a good start.
And that's all I ever wanted to do. That's beautiful. Yeah.
And seven's learning center is killing me.
I put the black crack babies in this white community.
Kids been reading since they were two.
They were whooping my black baby as Joe Joe Rogan, the tutors. I'm like,
fuck. They got all got along. I'm like, whoa.
I be glad when you crack babies catch up. I'll be glad when y'all catch up.
We gotta get this podcast take off. Yes, yes, yes.
Normally the TV show these days, you don't just need that podcast to keep going.
I know. And I'm enjoying it too. I didn't hit perfect for it.
Like that's what we were talking about the comedy store last time I saw it,
four o'clock in the morning. I was like, you've got to, you have to. You right.
You right. And I really like it too. I knew you. I was like,
this doesn't make any sense that you don't have one. Yep. And I mean,
I'm enjoying it. 30 minutes they'd be like, Oh, Ms peg, give me more. I'm like,
excuse me, I'm sitting here with no wig on. No Bra, no bag.
And Chris might be smelling me after 35 minutes. This is all you going to get.
Plus, you know,
he come over at four three o'clock and then my baby's coming in the door at four
o'clock so I'm gonna sit down, I'm screaming and hollering.
I got to go fix food and I got a life. I'm married. I can't sit down for,
you know, 30 minutes is fine. And I like it. As long as you're consistent,
that's the whole thing is like be consistent. Don't take weeks off. Like when,
when people take like four weeks off, five weeks up, people forget.
And then they're not interested in your podcast anymore. But if you,
if you just consistent and just keep doing it, people get,
it becomes a part of their routine and then they tell people you've got to
listen to miss path podcast. And next thing you know by word of mouth,
it just spreads. Yeah. I mean we have so many episodes in the bank.
How many of you have, I think we got probably 20 anybody fall? Yeah,
they wasn't as good as the ones that I put out regular. But you know,
when I first started I was kind of shy and I'm like, oh, I'm subbed.
And you know how, look I'm at a times you have to say,
what the fuck did you just say back? You're not shy. I was shocked.
That's the last word I would ever use for you fight. But I'm kinda shy Joe.
I mean, you know,
because I'm country and people are like the book that she was like I did.
I actually talked about you on my first one. So when I first did your podcast,
it was a story out that Joe Rogan is a bad ass and he choked on a mountain lion.
And I was like, I don't want to go talk to no white man.
I've got a fucking mountain line that's a made up story know.
But I didn't know at first and I was so scared.
Joe and I guess a mountain lion killer.
I'm used to black people doing dry by them.
I used to white people just chucking out a mountain lie.
So I'm trying to figure out how to fucking get up on a mountain line. And
how do weapons sneak up on a mountain lion from behind and took the shit out of
him. He gotta be strong as fuck.
So I kept digging and I realized the store wasn't Raja.
I didn't want to talk no white dude a choke that started,
you know, I see you with that big old weight and shit.
That'd be gonna Hoyas Hey was, I know he killed that fucking mountain line.
It took a while for me to realize that it took about two,
about a month before I realized the store wasn't very well.
Sister didn't think of my own sister. Thought it was real, really texted me.
She goes, you really choked her out. Fuck is wrong with you.
You bad as you. I mean only you can sneak up on a mountain.
Lion choked the shit out of it.
I've run with a knife. When I run, I, I carry a knife with me just in case.
Cause there's mountain lions in my community. Really? Yeah. They've seen him.
Yeah. And I run with my dog and the mountain lion tries to Jack me or my dog.
I want to have something on me.
So you, you, if he jack your dog, you're going to stab him. Fuck yeah. You know,
I was just telling the story about my, you know, I'm from the south, right?
So back in the day and don't get offended people but you know dog fighting is
big in itself so we didn't fight like no dangerous shit.
We just put some down ladies on the ground who have a dog get the best they
went. And Now lady, when my dog was named pup pup now or later,
you mean like candy now and laters the candy candy have the dogs fight over
candy? Yeah, we should showed them.
Me and my dog used to split the candy or whatever.
So I get some candy. Black dogs used to eat anything back then,
collard green peak feet, whatever. Black boots.
Black people didn't buy dog food. So we will, we will,
me and my dog will fight a lot but if you got the best of my dog I would jump in
and whip your dog gas goes out.
You wasn't to with my old last German shepherd and then I'll be calling him and
talking about I'm abusing the dog cause on our own. No fucking dogs.
I got full crack babies and I don't have an anathema.
This was back in the day and I was a little girl, but that's what we used to do.
It is a
big thing in the south period.
I knew a guy who had 30 pit bulls in his backyard. He had these uh,
boxes like that. He would,
the dogs lived in these little dog houses and they were chained to a post and
they were in his yard and I didn't see it. My friend was telling me about it,
but I knew the guy and he lived down. I lived in Kentucky.
Yeah, we lived in Kentucky and um, they fought dogs.
Well we, we only did it with just kids. We only like, well the,
I bet who have a dog get the best who have a dog. They w that's the winter now.
Right. So if I thought pop, but we're about to get, go down on his back.
I jump in and put your dog in a choke hold. Cause I like wrestling.
I will fix it. Yeah, I will fit, fold the shit out of your dog.
I was not losing them. Now Lady Joe, we didn't eat a lot.
I can lose my only meal that day. Your only meal was an hour later.
Some days it may pop up. Was It on the side? Why? Like we whipped his head,
they will pop up and we'll split the now later. Wow.
There's a lot of people right now listen, like as this lady for real.
And I can assure you, assure them that you are. I'm for real young,
kinda crazy fucking life, you know?
I mean there's so many people that are insulated from the kind of life that
you've had. They don't know anybody like you. You know?
So I'm realizing that Chris, my producer, I scare the shit out him. He's like,
why are you yelling at me? I'm like, Chris, I'm not yelling.
You'll know in a black woman the yellow, she got a twist and holiday,
they taken off a wig and I'm buckling hot, Bro. I'm yelling,
I'm just talking about voice. I have a deep voice in this. It carries, uh,
you know what's crazy? Cause, like I said,
he's a little white kid from Indianapolis and so I'm talking to on a podcast and
I'm teaching them about Black Pussy incense. You ever heard of that?
Black Pussy incense? Yeah.
You know that you burned the black people use a button in the house.
I know about incense, but if nobody called Pussy, he slow me down.
It wasn't real. So we put out the podcast, everybody's like,
my mama say black pussy is, it was the best sin out there Joe. Okay.
You look like, what did it smell like? I like incense. Yeah, I know the name of.
And I told Joe, I told him about him. He like, what are you talking about?
I'm like,
I'm telling you black puzzle isn't everybody listen to Art Keller in burnt black
plus it says on a Saturday morning, clean the house.
Everybody listened to r Kelly and burnt black. Oh Shit.
So every weekend,
every week I'm teaching them something that he has never heard of.
What do you think about all this art, Kelly Shit.
Um, I think you did it Joe. I mean people just look, if people just looked away,
you know, if I tell a beat on stage, I say something about a big Dick Man,
big Dick. Black man, they can't read. They puts it down. They have
every, they put it up.
My first kid father couldn't read when they ain't got no side teeth and they can
read, they got the best six cause they practice all the time.
Black men who can't read, don't,
don't have safe like black men who got a nine to five who can read the sex is
totally different because they're not tired because they practice audit doing
practice on women. But you got my husband got to go to work, Joey,
he got tired of me flipping me over, slapped me across the head.
Yeah,
you got time on at ghetto love. Oh my God.
He gets on him on and get on.
Well when you got a brother that can't read and don't work the best six,
now he ain't gonna go to work.
But he gonna Watch the young and the wrestling and housewives of Atlanta.
But when you know, when he get back, then that dig is laying on that pillow.
Well are you,
I know Whitney used to wade through everybody
[inaudible]
and you know he had to work even harder because you had more money than him,
right? Yeah,
that's true.
So they had a meme they put up on the Instagram the other day of a how every
dude whose girlfriend is paying for everything stands and it's like a guy
standing with his arm deep around the girl,
like deep around holding onto her while they're waiting in line for things.
Baby in public, always baby holding a hand.
You can't get my hold and hold my hand. [inaudible] you paid a mortgage?
I call home. Yes. I say I love you. Say thank you. I'm in the bay.
I was on the phone, my friend one day motto. So I say, listen to my husband,
my husband, funny as fuck. So I said, hey. I said, oh baby,
you want some pussy? He say, not at all.
Not at all.
My friend said, daddy say not at all.
And I think that's what he's knowing already.
Oh yeah, that type of relationship was it. Hey,
I'm gonna need you to fuck me on 14 cause I think I'm out of the lane.
I need to get some stuff. I'm a chance if
he's say not at all. Jo, we bought a sleep number bed and he was like,
cause he's knee with myth along body sleep number bed.
I'm gonna put it out every night. I'm like fuck yeah.
So I just gotta deal with Fox for my TV show. So I'll walk in now.
I walk in the damn mom sleep number like a real negro when they get some money,
give me the best fucking batch you won't cause I'm all fuck every night.
Okay.
Oh meal 13,000 now sleep number. Bam.
Well I should have no you weren't going to do shit cause he was insistent on
getting the metro. They split down the middle.
You know the two matches are separate that she split down the middle and now out
their time. I want to, I'll say I got 10 by eight.
You want to come to American gets [inaudible]
you've
got the harder button side.
No worries. I fuck with you own a mattress to cell phone out.
Come on here and then net. We don't gave it.
We did fuck in the middle and by the time we get through it and fucking Metrans
I'll fill out the man cause we in the middle of the whole app and everyone's,
I'm just chill. So she had just the remote,
my wig, everything. Soon
as I get my TV show home, buy me a magic. Pull those back. The fucking Gal.
Yeah, I didn't like that. Sleep number bed. I tried the thing.
I was too confusing. I didn't like it. Oh he loves the Joe.
Every time I come home he got his feet in the air.
Like he had a gynecologist visit one of those. Yeah. He thought, I'm like,
this measure is only good for heating your balls or we could've got you a blow
dry. You heating your balls up.
They sell mattresses now that cooled you mark system was, yeah.
I'm wanting to get one that seems awesome.
[inaudible] was just telling me about that. I'm going through menopause.
I might need to get that through. I'll be heating up. Joe. He, oh my tea.
I'm like,
I'm having a hot flash now and I don't want to drop my titties on your table,
but boy ass in here. I don't feel it, Joe,
when you get turn the AC AC can't stop. No high flash. It's like five minutes.
I'm heating up now. But yeah, it goes away. What does that cause?
But I don't know. You gotta ask Mary.
I don't know what Mary did in the beginning. It was married with Jesus.
No Mirror with Jesus. When did Jesus Momma only the Bible.
What do you mean Mary? Mary who but who do you mean when you're saying marriage?
No, I'm sorry. I'm talking about eve. Who Stopped? Who started here yet?
I'm sorry. I get that. Oh Damn Bitch. She fucked everything up. Yeah.
Every time I got talking snake. Yeah, that talk is Nate. I mean,
I'm cramps ain't no joke and now I'm having high feds y'all because this bitch
better apple. God, can you get me an opportunity to buy the apple?
I won't bite the Apple. Take the half.
I'd be on a plane with to heat up and wipe me and next to me don't understand
why I got my TV and my lap
fairing yourself off. Yes, yes.
It comes and goes like last five minutes and then the last few minutes and then
they go back to mom and like I'm cooling down now.
So like out of nowhere you just get hot. Yeah.
And they hit you in different places.
Like Mies is good between my titties on my neck,
some people's up under their arms, you know,
so a spot like one smile hit me right here and my titties, my titties heat up.
Like if you touched them that about 95 degrees,
don't touch him because you married.
But I'm just saying I don't want you to burn your fingers. Here it goes.
More than two thirds of North American women who are headed into menopause have
hot flashes.
They also affect women who start menopause after chemotherapy or surgery to move
their over it. It doesn't say anything. I'm why it's North American.
That's what I was wondering. It says, what is a hot flash?
It's a sudden feeling of heat. Sometimes a red flushed face and sweating.
We don't know exactly what causes them,
but there may be related to changes in circulation.
I guarantee you if they happen to men, they know exactly what caused them. Oh,
they'll fix that shit. They figured out. Oh yeah, they'll fix that joke if they,
if they can fix a soft penis. Yeah, they'll fix a man Dick.
But then we can't do nothing with all body.
Stop fixing soft dicks and everything else to be solved. No,
I don't think that would work. They're already fix
that. So they can't say stop fixing it up to like unlearn.
They'd have to unlearn Viagara look, just let the man dig. Do what it do.
When it dilated that, then that's,
that's the point where the lady need the notes.
You need to put some cocoa butter up on the hip is loud across it back.
Okay.
I don't think that's going to help either one is always over right, I guess.
Yeah. Yeah. People,
I think that they would be happy when it's over like good. Finally,
women are happened when they peers don't come on my walk and me and be happy
when a penis don't work.
Cause for men like your Dick not working as a sign of you don't,
you're not a man. Yeah, for sure. Ooh. Yeah.
You feel like you're not a man anymore. Oh really? Yeah.
So I don't feel like I'm not a woman. I'm old. My peers, Scott, we'd be happy.
Yeah. But it's different. If you pussy dried up and became useless,
like sealed up
like nothing. You know, like maybe you meet a man,
maybe you and your husband get divorced. You met a man, he's beautiful.
Can read. So he's got good Dick and he going to put it in.
It's like just a mess down there. Oh yeah, yeah. No,
I'm black. It grow real thick. So it's always a mess down there.
Yeah. I call it nappy grill. We've got a Jackson five and fro
[inaudible]
well, I mean for some women it matters.
But I guess because I started really early, I don't want no dick.
I want health care. Oh No. D you ain't gotta do that to me.
Just take you on a trip. I put for men though. It's like a sign of weakness.
It's a weakness then. Yeah. Yeah. You don't feel like a man anymore.
What if you love that person? I think you ready?
Are you willing to deal with the softness? Yeah.
Especially if you don't want any dick. Yeah.
If you want Dick and his duplex ice cream, ice cream sticks around it.
Oh, like a brace. Like someone, a broken leg.
You break your leg in the forest and they want to fucking strap it to some twigs
. What else do they was doing before by came along?
I don't know what they were doing. Let's just get them in the freezer.
Do it too. Out. That's what, that's why they kill rhinos. You know Rhino Horn,
they think rhino horn gets your dick hard. Really? It doesn't do shit.
Do you eat it? They, I guess they make a tea out of it. Oh really?
It doesn't even work.
But guys who've been taken Rhino Horn forever to try and get their dick hard and
so much so that now that it's forbidden and it's expensive because it's
forbidden. It's like a sign of luxury,
like you're drinking rhino horn t it's a big thing.
And apparently some Asian countries like with like really wealthy people.
Then we have Dickson Asian, they go home. I mean I heard they was small.
You're heard. Well I have a girlfriend. Yes.
Six Asian babies right here. But she don't
have any scratch Mars. Well, and I was just telling babies, you know,
most women get stretch marks. Right. But I don't think that has to do with Dick.
But I'm saying Asian means make small babies.
So I'm just assuming. Well what happened? It's like go,
I don't know what the fuck I'm talking about.
I missed the basketball player was the the the giant dude. Yeah. Yeah man.
What about that guy? Even if he has a normal size, he too tall.
He ain't got no Dickies. Two, two,
two tigers guarantee you he pissed on top of his pants.
It's a, it's a way a man, bro. James is tall too. He got a lot of Dick.
I saw that nick on TV that day. I bet. Oh my God. When he went to go scratch.
I was like, I'm not into young Dick like that. But that was nice and I said,
I tell you somebody else who got a nice, oh, Nicki Minaj ex boyfriend safari.
He broke the Internet with it. He broke down and that was, oh my God.
Here the curve. Any Joe fucking lip you can ask.
It could probably live a weight in this fucking weight room right here.
It was so big he couldn't even fit on the iPhone. It was only iPad action.
I was sending this to everybody. Bitch, look, you blessed today.
You blessed and he made a little five minute video.
That thing was swinging like the American flag on top of a building.
It was nice for my stomach done. Once I finish losing weight, don't do it.
Don't why I want my titties lifted. You don't know my tennis
Joe Getting put under is what I worry about. Well Shit.
I mean I want my titties lifted this hall when you got big titties and they all
in your lap and shit when you bro come off.
Do you want your wife to walk out the shower?
Her TD looked like they'd been in a drive by. I feel you.
I understand what you're saying. Yeah, so I want my tickets lifted.
I want money. Just my stomach done. I'm wanting to stay alive, Ms Palace.
I'm going to stay alive. I love you. I love you too.
I'm going to get me a verge. Juven nation too. Don't do it. Don't do it.
Don't get a tightened up.
I thought you said you don't even want anymore Dick White at the time.
Going through pen in line. It's like pamphlets.
Oh my God. But we'll rejuvenation fix that. I don't know,
but I got a leak that upon we came. Vic.
You know what's happening here? Just coffee. [inaudible] I'm wearing.
He's my friend Y'all.
That's the only reason I can tell him I be pissing on my shelf.
That's all right. I mean, I don't want no,
I don't want no Kim Kadash in them. Doma knows and I,
I'm okay with my black nose. I don't need it. Thank you.
Oh my cheeks pulled back. Joe.
I would like to get my stomach done so I can see my vagina.
It's been a long time. We'd been disconnected for a long time.
Have you ever gone on a diet? Yeah. Didn't like it.
I lost a hundred pounds and it just stopped, so I caught it. Not Bad.
It's like it stopped. He was like, Oh, you gotta go to the gym? I'm like, no.
I'll see. He lost a hundred pounds. Just dieting. No,
I w have weight loss surgery.
Two years ago when I first came out was real juicy. I was almost 400 pounds.
So you had this stomach staple thing? No, I, yeah, my stomach could. Yeah. Yeah,
it was. It was, it was easy as hell. Really? Yeah. I'll, I was,
I was almost ready at four. Wow. And I lost like,
you lost a hundred pounds and then they told you go to the gym and you're like,
fuck you. Well, I'm just so busy and I just a fucking excuse skews. I mean,
watching the trainer, that could be another podcast.
You complain and at the gym, that Shit would be hilarious. Yeah.
Would be complaint. That would be hilarious or something crazy.
My kids effect cause you lived the pants is fat. The kids are fat.
My son was 410 pounds.
Joe and I live in this white neighborhood and they couldn't get no pussy and
literally went on a diet joke.
When I tell you this is 220 pounds and every night when we go to bed he go in
the Pantry, throw away the junk and I said, you got one more time.
Throw away my motherfucker food. He's like, y'all can't eat that.
He read everything. He just go to the gym. He was fat as fuck. That's kitties.
His titties gone. His stomach flat every different day. What does he do?
What kind of exercise? I don't know. I can call him his name. June bug.
June bug. Yeah. Not his real name. He's, that's his nickname. Nickname.
Jim Addict. He's into the fucking gym ad and he's beautiful. He told, he's like,
I'm going to make this whole family lose weight. I said, not today bitch.
Show ass. Why don't you do a podcast
and Mama at the gym? Oh God, funny.
A video of you at the gym would be just you complaining and talking Shit.
When somebody gets you to workout, be God damn hilarious. Juma,
we're going to do a podcast, but he gonna try to kill me jail.
But if you just listened to him and did it and did a video,
I guarantee you that would get a shit load of views. Okay,
well me and Junebug do my weekend. You're going to help them up. Actually,
I'm getting ready to move to La for the pilot of my shelf.
You're gonna move here. I'm gonna move here for a little bit. For how long?
Well, we gonna shoot the pilot. So if the pilot get picked up at Hulu,
so I'd be here doing the shoot and then I'm gonna go back home.
I can't take all these nice titties running around,
so I'm going to bring junebug out with me trying to start fresh to start filming
video you all to seemed like he had big titties. Like mines. They're gone.
Beautiful. I love it. I love stories like that. He just did it.
I know what it was. He couldn't get laid. Well that'll be a motivator. Yeah.
And I asked him, I said, son, be it, cause he told me, he said Mama,
cause I mean I'm doing a little bit now.
I probably lost like 15 pounds since I've been dealing with jumbo. He say, Mama,
when you lose weight, when you start to lose weight,
he just text me when they said, dude, come on your period.
What do you mean I'm your fucking mom? And he's like
in the room when these conversations are happening. I said,
why are you asking me? He said, cause when I help you lose weight,
your period can come back. I said,
why I fucking period is not who come with your son a doctor? I don't know.
He just read out. It's I'm old Joe. I lost like 12 pounds in my peer kb.
I said, he was like,
I know Momma you stopped up from all the fat. I said
stop, stop.
He told me all stopped up Joe. But my cycle came. I'm like,
what the fuck you do to be my Mama? The more I work with the moe,
you going to flow. So He's right. That's what's crazy.
Yeah. He just reads a lot about fitness and health. He's, I'm telling you, Joe,
how old is he? He's 19 and what is he doing? He works, he works at enterprise.
He, he should get together with you. Fuck Enterprise.
It's just you two together working out, making youtube videos. So it'd be huge.
Yeah. Especially if I can get down to like him. He's like,
my mom kind of get you in shape and my daughter is on a plus size too.
He's like, I'm whipping all y'all ass all because he just, he just,
he just popped up saying, I'm sick of being fat. That's awesome.
He said he was sick of being fan. My baby, if you go to my Instagram,
he's on it. He, and he's even, he's two 29 I'm like, jumbo stop. He's like, no.
Wow. I mean he got a cheers, Joe [inaudible]. He looks good.
And I asked him, I said, son did you did get bigger?
Cause I remember really smile.
He was like, it's better Mama. It's bad.
When you're fat, your Dick gets smaller.
Your naval become your Dick when you real fat Joe.
Oh my God, you should do that. Oh look, I talked you into doing a podcast.
I'm going to talk you into doing this. You have to, okay.
Junebug I know you're going to see this meal
bug please. You and your mom at the gym. It'd be gigantic. I'll help you.
I'll promote it. I'll put it up on Twitter and Instagram. Please do this.
Joe Egon. Kiyomi. Okay, you go, I got to go in there with a d P in. Oh wait,
if he gets you in crazy shape, imagine if you get to like bikini shape.
Seriously. I ain't been like that since the third grade
bikinis shaped. I'm telling you, Joe, you could do that though. He does that.
Joe,
you don't know how happy I would be if I could just look straight down and see
shit. At
times. The food that you crave is the food that you eat,
so if you eat food that's not healthy for it,
that's where you're craving all the time and your stomach gets used to it.
The what they call your gut biome. Your stomach bacteria wants sugar,
bread and pasta. As soon as you start eating healthy food,
your body starts craving healthy food.
Your body will start craving salads and lean meat and chicken and fish.
I don't know what else
he started. We don't drink water but I do now. He makes me drink.
Well he literally call me Mama cause I can do one liter a day.
I'm up to one liter. That's no cause. What do you drink besides water?
I drink coffee in the morning and then after that, no more coffee.
I have to have one cup. Coffee is fine. Yeah I do put sugar and cream in.
I got full Craig Baby. I need something to call my to him. So I told him my son,
I can't give up my call for right now.
So I drink coffee only in the morning and then I drink water all day.
I work on a liter of water and he literally go through the House and tell us
what we can and can't eat,
which is I'd be want to punch him in the face but I am losing a few panels with
him. Like you know I got,
I got the back wheel arms like Grand Mama and he was like, mom,
I'm gonna get all of that off with you. Cause he was,
he had fed arms too and big titties.
I mean he lost all of it and I'm so good you could do it too.
Yeah cause I was told them, I said,
look you 19 you're on the insurance at 26 they would give you weight loss
surgery. And he's like, I don't want that. I said, son,
go get the weight loss surgery.
Then I get your titties taken off and your stomach took. He's like, mom,
that don't sound like no manly thing.
I heard it all played out.
Tommy took his titties cut off and y'all don't get them weight loss surgeon and
my fat daughter, she fat and I said, I'm gonna get your Tommy Toe.
I'm going to get your stomach cut and then I'm gonna buy you a ne it's cause she
had no ass. So, and then I told my husband he don't have no ass.
I was going by him, my ass.
Jesus Christ.
Everybody asks us [inaudible] people are getting cancer from that as is that
when they take the fat from, you know, not only to take the fat,
they getting a lot of fat. They getting cancer from the implants. What?
Titties ass implants. Oh, I ain't gonna do no, I asked him to do that.
I got bigger. You do. There's no issue. But some people who get asked implants,
they're starting to get cancer. I'll ask him. Plants are only a few years old.
And you know what? I don't understand. I'm from the inner city of Atlanta.
When we was coming up, Joe, if you want it titties and ass,
and they had this thing going around and I did a podcast on it. I said,
we didn't people, black people didn't know what plastic surgery was.
So the deal was you take that government butter and you rub it on your titties
and your ass and they said it'll make it grow. Yeah, I'm not lying to you.
That's what we used to do back in the day. Watch up. Look at me. Yeah, but look,
look at me. Don't think it's from the butter. Ah, ever. Ever been.
I Know Rob Butler.
You don't know that government [inaudible] I want a job.
They said to the ghetto to kill everybody. Joe.
I got say these stories at once. I was in the tub and [inaudible] was like,
just put the butter on your TDA, your ass. We put the bottle all on my Mama.
Wait, cause she's like, no, you bitches. They got my bottle on Ya.
You know that shit. Gotta last me Tornado. Mo Day she took this,
did you call it? And she hit. Doesn't that motherfucker stuck in that bottle?
She gave us one woman who she say sprayed my shit off you bitches.
We're not hot bar all of us. She put that, she making a frigerator.
She beat the shit out of. Oh my God.
She scraped a butter off your tits and put it back in the fridge.
We will pull, we can waste on that good bottle of Joe. Oh my God.
That is hilarious.
She beat this year I was playing and her butter magic butter really did that.
All you had to do to get big tits and a big ass. Just even butter.
I have him t this is the fourth grade. So that's when I did it.
Like you just have good genetics. Now tell my Mama didn't have no titties. Yeah,
but sometimes it doesn't get your mom but it goes to,
you know I'm trying to kill the government. Don't do that.
Education and shit. Joe, go break it all the way down for the lady.
Let them try to butter they phone. They try to pause it. Okay,
so go out and get you some good old government Butler that won't mail and just
sit on it like a, like, like a fucking bird trying to hit your eat.
Just sit right. Yeah. Just rub it on your booty and stuff.
Just have a seat on it and hopefully it'll make your booties and tds. Girl,
your brother for me, if it didn't work, imagine if that works.
There's a lot of questions on Yahoo people asking that does make your butt
bigger and then I found a product called buck butter
cream for smoother, fuller, and firmer skin. I don't know if that's what I had.
Yeah,
natural but enhanced. We cream for women and men.
Plump booty enhancer lotion but firming and tightening cream sexy but was it?
Hold on. Sorry. Sexy Butt lifter cream button. Larger Green.
This is horse shit.
There's most likely it's got four stars.
[inaudible] bunch of people that are assholes that work for the company.
They're reviewing it 364 customer reviews. Hold on,
click there.
I used to read this one or a bad one.
The good ones adding to my flat booty.
My family and I and my family,
I inherited flat Butt Syndrome. It's embarrassing.
It's embarrassing.
Have your butt hurt because you have no padding when you sit and have no pants
fall, have your pants fall because there's nothing in the back to hold them up.
After a week I def notice something extra in the back. I'll keep using.
That's the people that you want to buy your butt cream cause they're morons.
That's like people that give money to preachers that fly on private jet.
Yeah. I think that's crazy. That don't work. But I, I'm telling you,
gum and butter work, Joe, I'm telling you. Let's look at this.
Who would've known it works faster on your breasts and on your butt,
but it's work. [inaudible] this is not real. It is real. Looking at me.
I'm my forties
I can't see shit
when you yell with those giant glasses on. So funny God.
But listen to these fucking, the people that are writing these reviews,
not only does it works, that's it works. Not only does it works,
it increased my breast size.
They probably should change the name to breast and button hands, pant, butter.
I know it for the butt. I know it for the buck. So I figured, let me see,
will it do anything for my breast since it's in quotes, all natural.
So I did. So within a week,
my breast was fuller. Last time I seen them.
This size was right before it was time to breastfeed and my baby is now nine
years old.
Oh, so imagine that what we was doing in the ghetto,
I'm telling you that thick as butter does work.
Watch, I made it. People who knows what I'm talking about from the south.
Say Joe, we did that and it worked out.
So my routine is we should have done it on one titty.
Did it just to see no John wanting to be here. I know,
but it is only one way to find out that actually works. One cheek, one tick.
You bounce it out. Left cheek, right tip.
I'm going to find that button button and rub it on my crack baby.
One of her titties and see if they grow in their head.
Just don't even tell them what you're doing. Just put it on one titty. I okay,
I'm gonna have to get her to do it. I don't think I feel appropriate.
How old is she now? She's not. It's too late. No, no. She's uh, no. At Four.
You can do it. You have a five year. I can test it out.
She already got a big gaze booty. Oh yeah.
Then I'm going to come and get some of that and see if it works.
My husband would kill me. I don't know if it's true but I don't think it is.
It doesn't make sense. But then again, I'm not a scientist.
I'm telling you it's like that peanut butter that they used to send to the
ghetto to choke negros out.
I love you too. What did they do?
That peanut butter that they used to send to the gut.
The government used to give black people,
peanut buddy Joe come out cause they didn't want to talk about that thick peanut
butter. You had to heat in the might.
You want a microwave to heat it on the stove.
Like you better cook up scrambled egg for now.
So he get sprayed it on the sandwich. Really?
Then they find out later on they were gonna kill us. It was like,
it was thick as fuck. It came in a cane. The Goldman peanut butter.
Good googling.
There was some dude on Instagram who was in school,
some kid in school and they were there. They, you know,
they feed them cheese sandwiches for lunch and he was lighting the cheese
sandwich. He was like, look at this cheese, look at this shit.
And he's lighting. He's got a lighter to, it would not melt.
It was just turning black. It was just getting black from the smoke,
from the lighter. It was not melting. It wasn't,
what the fuck kind of cheese is this.
Yeah. And it wasn't real cheese.
There's this parts of America that the government ignores, right? Yeah,
man. Yeah. You got through. I got through.
He made it through the net. But, but didn't they only come to you when they,
when they need your vote? They only come to the, like black pastors.
They like black pastors, you know? That's why I don't go to church.
I tell them all the time. I taught at churches, chicken,
you get more for your money. Churches. Chicken's better.
$2 Tuesday, get you two piece chicken in a biscuit.
Popeye's alone on Tuesday and go to churches. Yeah,
but did they have the spicy this Jannie got spices now. Yeah. Yeah.
That's the thing. I'm like, I'm not giving no pastor my money. Good for you.
And ride not there. I mean, Hey, the Bob is free.
Then every hotel just did abide by the hotel like everybody else used to.
I'm not going to give you my money.
Then you are here by buying jets and shit and I'm struggling.
Then you fucking holes in church. Rini sharing holes in church. No.
Nomo they're fucking hoes. Oh yeah, they beat so fuck you. I don't know.
I don't go to church holes. Go to church with no underwhelm to get the pastor.
Oh fuck the first lady, they don't kick them back. The first lady
goes where? No underwear in church to lure the pastor. Really?
You ain't much. The pastors is sexy as fuck.
I remember back in the day when you might not remember cause you white,
but begging and begging a date.
The pastor was ugly. Oh, the passable ugly. Like TD Jakes.
They was on fuckable but now they all sexy.
Then they all sexy me. Everybody want fun?
No,
that's what they said they made when they made Catholic Cheetah preachers become
celibate.
One of the reasons why the Mandan become syllabus because the Catholic preachers
were banging all the ladies and they were like, damn,
they were like rock stars because they were the ones who had the word of God.
And this is before anyone could read the Bible because it was all in Latin.
So they did not read Latin. So they relied on these priests to read it.
Look at Joel Osteen. Yes, he's fuckable. Oh yeah, I haven't. Don't imagine so.
Yeah. Do you think he gets him?
I give him song and not in Jesus' name.
He's sexy shit.
I don't even do white men Lauer do Joe Austin in the pool pit.
Do you think he gets him? He got a wife. Yeah, but other than her,
hey bitch
fucking with me Joel Osteen
and I let him call me that too. Yeah, you pay the bill. Get Him.
He killed any age at,
Oh look at that for here to hell.
He's 60 he won't give me his faithy. I bet he does have a six pack,
right? Yeah, you looks good.
Hey was that his wife and the upper right hand corner?
Go back 56 looks good for 57 for a white man. Look, go though.
Is that his wife? She's hot. Yeah. She hasn't played with, they're called,
let's say it's his wife. Kapow. Yeah, he could take that. Joel.
Joel is good looking. It's got a god named Marina. Yeah, church has got they.
They are the new drug though. They're the new pimps.
Pimps had holes and they go on a cone and slept.
They hold and get their money or church like that. Now that's all it is.
He does it in Vegas at the same arena where the UFC plays.
I thought he was in Dallas. He goes all over the place. He goes on the road.
Sometimes they go on the wall and he's in Houston or Dallas somewhere in Texas.
Houston, so he does that,
but he also does like giant arenas on the road like he does.
He does the a t mobile center, whether UFC place.
Look at that as far as that place now you can keep that.
How many of those pitches in the audience have no underwear on?
Probably about 60%
great.
Just stop going to church when they started charging for meals.
I don't fuck with no junk. Oh my God. No, you ain't noticed that.
I didn't know that they were banging on the churches mail. The front row.
Well is smell like an oyster card? Yeah.
Is smell like Appalachian population? Yes. They joke. Hey,
that's how you have a baby by a man like Yo. Oh, sneaky paying jobs. Pope Oh,
time. Yeah. I would imagine if you're,
if you're the type of person that wants that much money, right.
You want that much money. You want private jets, you want big houses,
you gotta want some extra posting.
Hell yeah. He go get tired of paying the same plastic face. White woman.
She looked good. Yeah. [inaudible] get tired of him when he was on my,
like me with the t too. They move on the inside. Move on the inside. Yeah.
You know I got the real Tito so much. You'd go all over the place. Oh,
when Herzer. Yeah, they just from, they just one position up straight.
That's weird that people like that. They like them harden. Yeah,
I got them teed. You got to pick up and dust.
Oh, slop.
No does cause everything in my bra. Oh God.
I like how gross
you don't be at home like this bitch. Yo, I'm telling you something.
Tell just the other podcasts we've done with.
I'd stop in the middle of the dangle the fuck.
Oh yes. Some of the shit. Well mostly about the tragedies.
Mostly about your childhood.
It's funny now Joe, it's just that I took out, you know, I, I I see on stage,
I said, um, ah, when you, when you,
when you can laugh at what you've been through, then you got control of it.
It is only reason why I can laugh about being shot. And I even,
my husband hate this bit. I do. I do a bit about my first gay, his father,
you know, giving me crab's gonna rain fleas,
please. Jeez combo with no toy.
Fucking fleas. I mean, people get crabs, I get it.
But when someone gives you fleas, like what the fuck? But back in those days,
the health department would come and pick you up and say, Hey,
you put me on fire. We need to put it out. They pick you up,
pick you up in [inaudible] he beat him, gave somebody else crap.
Gonna run Fleece on some bitch report.
Everybody he was missing and I was always on the list. Oh Geez.
How can you tell people they,
I think it's funny that they used to come get me and me and the health
department man had a relationship. Now we weren't sleeping together.
He just say, hey you, plus it was on the list again.
Like how can you tell people? It's fucking hilarious. I don't have a STD,
but I was young. You know who's it was simple shit. Gunnery,
you're going to shout in. Yeas. And I remember they came one time, Joe and um,
they knocked on the door and I said, oh my God, you here.
I thought you was gonna let me borrow it up. And he's like,
you put some on this, let me here to put it out
is on the list. Pretty much. Call it your pussy. He said,
you put the bit reported. Okay. So my kid,
his father was down. I was like, let's go together and get cured. He's on,
I don't want to go. Somebody might see me. So this is what he told me. Say Look,
it was going to run when you have a gun already,
you need to get a shot or you take pills for seven days. So he said, look,
go to the health department, but don't get the shot.
Get the pills so we can split them. So I'm so stupid.
I come back and split the seven day pills with him and we still both got half of
it. Oh my God.
We didn't take the medication all the way. So, oh my God, stupid.
I was like walking while you tell people that shit and everybody always think he
gave me Gunnar Room and shot me and beat me like,
can you please tell the people I didn't do this shit to you?
How does he deal with you having this act like when you go on stage and talk
about all this shit, how does he handle it? Does he cover his ears? He,
he never, he only seen me once. Wait, what? He won't come see me. Joe, come on.
He wouldn't, he came to see me with Kat Williams,
asked him when I was opening for Kat Williams and um, but that's the only time,
but he's, he's gotta know. Oh he no funny as fuck.
Like how did you not want to see that? He don't want to see Joe.
We'll tell him to come to the comedy store tonight cause he going to be there
for the 10 30 show. Hell yeah, I am. But he's an even now.
Plus he'll watch your fucking podcast and tell my daughter, oh,
she was so fucking fun, but he's not going to direct it to say to me,
he was so fucking funny. But he's my biggest cheerleader. I mean, he's support.
I mean, you know, I've been doing this 17 years.
You know how many times I had to Max that man credit card out to go and do it.
So, you know, but he would not come see me. He's like, look, I live with you.
I hear this shit every day.
Well he gives me like, he's funny to me. Like I told you saying, not today.
I want to put it today. Yeah, not at all.
He says I'm going to funniest shit. Well he's, he, you know,
he was only seen you do comedy once the one time out of 17 years.
It's a good one though to open for Kat Williams. He's still in touch with Kat.
No, but I love care about it.
Tell me Shit about care where my daddy died or my daddy died and I had just got
a job with Kat Williams. He walked in and he was like what are you doing?
I said my daddy died like two days before.
He called me on a tour and I said we are trying to,
I'm just trying to get this money together, raising care. William,
go to the bank, come out with a stack of money.
He gave me like four grand to bear my dad and I was like you don't have to do
this. And I was like I'll work for, he's like look no go barrier daddy.
Cause before he did that I was about to put my fucking daddy on potato sack and
stick him in the ground cause we had no money.
And I tried to do a fish fry in the black community.
I mean the white neighborhood, they don't know nothing about no fucking fish.
Frown. No Tuesday and cat wouldn't gave me the money to bury them. That's hard.
Yeah. So can't nobody tell me shit about cat. Wait,
he's crazy. But he's funny as fuck. He's,
he's one of my favorites all the time and he tell the fucking truth too.
If you go to the bar, Go back to like the pimp chronicles is in his prime.
That is, those are some of the best specials ever. Yes.
He's a funny motherfucker and he's so original. That is him.
You know what I mean? Like his delivery, his style, everything.
I love him. Can't nobody tell me shit about no kit. We call the Cat William.
I was able to finish my basement after that tour.
He, uh, he gave me some, not gave me,
but he gave some great advice once about comedy. One of the things he says,
don't eat before you go on stage. And I was like, yeah, why would you,
you don't eat before you fight. Why would you eat before you go on stage?
Because it causes your body that your body when you eat has to break down that
food. So it's, it's using up energy,
like some of the energy that you would have to do stand up is now breaking down
that food in your body. That's why I be about to fall asleep. Yes.
Yes. Shit, I got to stop eating. Just don't eat right before you go onstage.
Just eat afterwards. Okay. Yeah, I mean I listen to him and I was like,
that makes so much sense.
And also he has a playlist of music that he plays right before he goes on stage.
Like sets it up. Like it's like puts him in the mood to go onstage. Yeah,
I do that too. I do that. I do that too. I like a lot of 'em.
Um, I, I don't want to say outcast, but that ain't what I'm going for.
Who the fucking rap. I, let's call it beat. Oh, that little nasty thing.
That's what I would be if I had a body like that. Oh my God,
that girl got a tone that a drag afloat. She might,
she that person in my head that I want to be. I listened to a lot of Carly B.
I like her.
Maybe you can get that body. Ah, maybe,
maybe June bug kill you in that gym.
Get on that elliptical machine. Come on
Zoomba we're going to need you to help your mom out and stop your mom from
peeing. I say
just just change up the Diet. I'm working. I swear God listen to your son.
I'm gonna look like you if you don't do that. Did they go too hard?
I tell you go to a different doctor. I'm lying.
But if you, if you did that,
I'm telling you if you did a video with your son and your son getting you to the
gym and did that regularly on Youtube,
June bug and miss pat just do that. That shit would be hilarious.
It'd be so funny cause I, cause you know I got lucky is out. I want,
especially when they're making you do shit,
you don't want to do like working out like doing sit ups and shit and squat.
Yeah. Spread my legs wide. It ain't been never been used at a wasted day.
Eighties. You bought it my butthole.
Exactly. Yeah. Yeah. We doing it. Do it, do it. Definitely do it.
So, so you do you bring like, um, I bring like one of those, um, um, uh,
MP3, no. Uh, Bluetooth speaker things with me. You know,
I have like one of those JPL extremes.
I bring that with me and I put it in the green room. Play music.
I usually listen to music on my youtube, my before perform. Yeah.
I listen to music on my phone. Yeah, but you get yourself in the mood. You do,
you have a drink before you go onstage? I don't drink alcohol at all.
No nothing. What about weed? I don't do any way. You don't know nothing.
I grew up in, up invite
me. As I say, I just don't, I mean, alcohol,
alcohol does nothing for me. It makes me sleepy. And, um, I,
my mom was an alcoholic and I used to always say,
I'm going to be nothing like this bitch. And so, so
yeah. So I don't, I don't do at my,
my whole family drink and I just don't do it. I don't, I don't smoke weed.
I don't, you know, I was just telling them earlier,
like junebug tried to smoke weed one time and with his white friends,
but they were so stupid, Joe, they didn't know how to roll the wheat.
So they got the, they got the, um,
the copy of paper off the machine and roll the weed in there. Yeah.
And Tommy leading it just burned and all the wheat filling his chest.
And I beat the dog shit out of jumbo. And I told him,
I don't grocery for you to create an appetite. You already fucking fat.
Oh my God. And I just told my kids when they was young, I said, look,
I told my son, I kid, I said, look,
I get food stamps and I don't get enough food stamps for your weed habits.
So we not gonna do drugs. We not going to join gangs, we not going to do drugs.
It's US motherfucker. So we not gonna do it. So,
but Junebug is the only kid I ever had that really tried to dab into weed.
That's a weird way to do it though. Copy paper. They was terrible.
They would go to the ghetto and buy the weed out of the, out of where I live at.
They would go over to the ghetto. So I said, Juma, how much you need?
How much wheat you buy? 1.5 grams. What the hell is that? I don't know.
And I called the police on him. I said, what are you I did.
I called the police on the shake him up. Right. And I,
you know called the police. Yeah. But I said, hey black. So leave your guns
in the car. So come over here and shake my son up. Napolese get over there.
The police and Junebug son go to school together. This man for,
come on and start crack. We love you. June. I said, holy cow,
you're a fucking crap.
[inaudible] I was crying so that didn't help.
But eventually I think he gonna stop smoking now he's going to stop or start.
I think he stopped. I ran off all his friends. I told him, I said, look, yo,
your white son just lost his only black friend. I'm a fucking white baby.
I bring him back over here with the weight
and do more like everybody at my school say you a snitch. I said fuck them.
I whooped him white boy, his ass.
Cause I called, I called on a pair so I called all the parents. I was like damn.
Well smoking weed and looking at some little white girl puts it on the phone and
I said, Juma, you bless your momma standing there.
But his wife puts it floating on the phones. Oh look a girl from the school.
Yes. So I put the, I put the,
I Chromecast the pitcher and I called out a Passat.
Who white baby puts these days. Yeah, you put it on the TV
off at me. Look, kick the bitches away from June bug Joe McGinn, Tim Grady,
Little Dick. It's real, real small redneck. I'm trying to kill my baby.
Trying to get my baby locked up for some white pussy.
Don't fuck with white plus you ain't got no, Vicki ain't got no sense.
Oh my God. So,
so you had the parents come over and tell them who white man,
what the fuck did they say? I can't believe you did this.
What the fuck you mean? That was on the phone. Y'all started looking at it.
They stormed about it. They wouldn't speak to me and no, no.
Fuck. La County, no phrase. Oh my God.
That's an old shoe ever in your life valley? No good.
She gave to one at a football player. He just passed it around everybody. Yeah.
And I told him, I said, jumbo, think about dude, you're supposed to Gary on him.
He's like, mom, Garren ain't getting naked at a deacon. Nobody see nothing.
Yeah.
That's just the stuff I went through where he's the only one that ever really
tried me. Cause my other kids, you know, I tell like I tell my crack baby,
I say, look, I'm going to take y'all out in public, but you got an option.
Do you want to get on mom or do you want the soccer mom and they don't like to
get on mom cause you get on.
Mama would knock the shit out of him in public and I give him option and we get
in public and white people always coming to me like oh my God,
your kids are so well disciplined. I said,
I told him I was going to fuck them up.
They say when you said they just look like what?
I said you should fuck your kids up to tell them.
I said Hey, I said I will fuck you up. Don't play with me the I feed you.
When we was coming back from the Disney cruise they was all playing with those
little things that separate, you know when you're alive.
So I told them like three full time stop isn't the my grand baby and there was
the full crack baby so they wouldn't stop Joe.
I slept all of them at the same time.
Why people like what the Fuck I say what you're looking at me for.
You all saw him too.
I asked him to stop by full time. Don't play with me, you know [inaudible] bad.
I'd been shot a couple of times. Yama. Fuck no, I'm crazy.
And I just tell them that they good kids. The good kids now.
Oh they knew I fucked them up.
I have a lot of bits about them because like [inaudible] like I do this bit
about, I used to do this bit about the teacher school calling me all the time.
White schools call you for anything and anything Joe. I mean just dumb shit.
Black schools. We tell them, look bitch,
that's your child to two 30 don't you wake me up. So one of the books I used,
one of the beats I used to tell,
they call me by my niece Yolanda because she was sitting at the crayon table
with hello white friends and they're talking about their daddies.
So Yolanda said, what? The next time I see my daddy,
I'm going to stab him in the neck and all the white kids started crying and they
asked me to come up there in an emergency to come up there to talk to them.
I get up there, I'm like, ma'am, she can't stab a dead end in nick,
the N***a in jail. Somebody else gonna stab him in the knee.
Don't wake me up with, don't wake me up for this bullshit.
So they don't know how to handle or anything. And I had to set the school down.
I said, look, these kids are from the hood.
They only talk and do what they know. You gotta give me time to help them grow.
But then they wanted to put them on medication. I said, what? We will. Yeah,
because they didn't know how to deal with them. They had this so,
so much like they momma was into horny daddy was in the drugs that they will be
known the mom and they, they didn't know how to handle him and I said, look,
we're going to help him grow together. I said, well, what we not going to do,
we're not going to put these kids on medication.
What we gonna do is surround them with love. They so good now out of five years,
this baby just now passing the I step test,
they took a minute to get there but he's finally there.
I step those pumps,
those standardized tests they give kids and the kids just wasn't ready and you
know I throw them in his neighborhood,
threw him in an environment that they wasn't used to and then you know they talk
they language. You see how country I am, what they talked straight streets.
Cause sometimes like what the fuck are y'all talking about?
We bout it about another fuck. You Ain't get better set up by bus.
You Cross your head. We bowtie Bowtie yeah they ready to rumble.
They ready to fight the little boy like I'm bout about,
I said put your fucking finger down. Far Braking.
But I had to retrain him because what he saw in the hood,
it wasn't going at my nice little white school. No
they were they good now they're good. Now imagine all the kids that don't,
and you can imagine cause it was you when all the kids who don't have someone
like you, what my niece is her 20 years old,
21 and she had six kids and she in jail for 20 years for knocking on people
doing robbing them. So her kids is in a situation.
So just imagine all the kids, I think about it all the time,
especially when it's my family member, but Joe, I had to realize this.
I can't say the world. You can't save everybody.
I try to save one at a time and that's all I can do. That's all you can do.
Yeah. That is all you can do. I can't say the world.
I mean I can't live if I keep trying to say the world. No, you won't.
You won't be able to do what you're doing is helping people too.
One of the things you're doing,
and it's helped me because you're making people laugh. Yeah,
that helps a lot.
Yeah, I do. People fucking need that. They need it so bad.
So many people right now with their headphones on in their cubicle laughing
their ass off right now. I hope so. Fuck yeah, they need it.
[inaudible] pet down at the Joe wrote Little Cadet for sure.
They're gonna subscribe. I guarantee you. I hope so 100%.
Let me, you know,
I was dealing show last night at the verge of here in La and uh,
a man came into me, said, man, my dog died today and I've been crying all day,
but I want to tell you how much you helped me fucking relieve I so I'm sorry
about your dog. Did you burn them up?
Turn them off. He actually started laughing, you know, after they die,
you got a barn about cremated cream in them.
Diags and let me actually started laughing, but I'm,
I mean I get that all the time and you know,
laughter is what he'll mean when I was able,
when I was able to write my book and you know, started doing comedy,
especially like it was one story now about my mama boyfriend who molest me. And,
um, I had never told this door over 30 something years. My husband didn't know,
only person knows me and my sister because he's all,
we happen to us at the same time with him. And uh, I never told this store.
And I remember when I was writing my book, the uh, lady who co-wrote my book,
she was like, um, you gotta tell the store. And I said,
well I got to ask my sister and I get my sister on the phone, Joe.
And I was like, may pop. That was on, that's her name. I said,
you ready to tell what Mr John did?
And we both just boohoo eh, we cheat.
We told some of the store,
we got off the phone and it took for me to tell his story.
It took almost a week me in the right across so much cause I had,
I had all of that built up in me.
But I'm so happy I was able to tell that story now because that was the only
story I had never told public about how my Mama Boyfriend d it,
me and my sister from the age of probably six or eight till I was 11 years old,
cause I started, my kids' father was 21 and I was 12 and I made him.
So I started having six eight 12. So when he started touching me, Mike,
when I got a boyfriend, my Mama, my mama boyfriend left us alone.
Once you got a boyfriend? Yeah. Once I got a boyfriend, Jesus Christ.
So that was the only story I had never told.
But when I told him I felt like I lost 20 I'm proud of a hundred pounds.
I felt like it, but it didn't go anywhere. Right. But I just felt oh, relief.
Yeah. So I know loud. I just know Lotta does a lot for me.
So I know it does the same for all the people. God Damn,
you had a crazy fucking [inaudible] and I live it every inch of it too.
Well it's, that's the only way you can, I mean, what you've done is, I mean,
you've done the ultimate take a negative and turn it into a positive. I try,
I try really hard. But you made me really happy cause your,
your sense of humor is so fucked up,
but it's because of your life that it's so fun. I mean, that's why it works.
If you had a cushy life and you were saying the shit that you say,
it wouldn't be funny. So it wouldn't be no.
And that's of the things with my husband,
like when I was shared with, and like my kid's father shot me and beat me.
You know, most of your listeners in Canada, who I am, they know my background.
And one of the things when I started sharing my life,
my husband had that protective Mo. He didn't want me to, you know,
he knew how negative the world could be when I started to share these stories so
I could see where he wanted to step in and protect me. Right. You know,
when people would judge me and you know,
like I dropped out of school in eighth grade when my husband went to the
military, went on off. He had a mom and Daddy, a way better life than me.
So he would always be there to like be that protector, like,
oh they think I'm stupid or [inaudible]. And I just, I just,
he helped me grow a backbone to know you'd say,
fuck what people think about you. You mean?
Cause there was so much screwed up stuff in my head. Like, um,
one of the theme my Momma taught me about white people.
I didn't deal with white people. I mean, let's be honest, I'm from [inaudible].
There was a police on the fucking on the case worker. My Mama told me, she said,
white people are better than you. Never look them in the fucking devil.
So my whole life, Joe Rogan, I was scared of white people. And when I,
when I wrote the book and I told The lady this, when I was see white people,
I would immediately look down what else, what the slaves used to do.
And that's what the book lady told me. And I was like, I can't look them in eye.
And then she was like, why?
And I told her the story and I told my husband his stories. He say, Pat,
he say we're all the same. Your fucking mommy is stupid.
Hello.
I used to sell a bit. I said,
the only thing between me and you white woman is my titties is bigger than
yours. But I was in,
I was in my late twenties when I learned it because you like I,
when I moved to Indianapolis I couldn't talk to you. I fucking,
my words will stump and I will immediately say I'm stupid and I will look away.
And when I started doing coming in Indianapolis and my fan base turned white and
I was like, why the fuck y'all like me? Get away from me, the shit out of you.
I say that to myself and my husband sent me down. I was like, Pat,
we all the same. Your fucking mom is stupid. I'm like, we are.
And I was in my late twenties but I had never ever dealt with white people.
Like I dealt with them when I moved into that community and I'm glad because it
taught me a lot as a young girl out of that,
out of the inner city of Atlanta that we all the same. The problem was,
the problem with this country is we don't fucking talk. Yeah,
we don't communication.
Well there's that. And then there's that.
These communities stay the way they are.
Like whether it's Baltimore where they had it set up or black people literally
weren't allowed to buy homes outside of certain areas or any inner city like you
know,
in inner city in Houston or New York or anywhere where the neighborhood stay the
same. They stay the same general state of war, crime, poverty,
all the drugs, everything stays.
And I don't, you know, Joe, my kids and I, my,
my kids up fucking, they blessed us and they don't realize how blessed they are.
And sometimes I get so pissed off at them like they go to this really nice high
school where I live in Indiana,
they get they little laptops and you know they get new books every fucking year.
Joe,
when I went to school it was so many niggles name wrote in that same book where
it hit done,
checked it out every year you had to flip a page and you just see Ramon,
Tyrone Tada, three pages of kids who had their books
and it pisses me off because you know I look at it and I was like well this is
the old curriculum where you know these my kids are getting a new curriculum
every year and it's still like that in certain parts of America and it pisses me
off. I'm like, yeah, you guys don't realize how blessed you are.
You come in through a fucking this fucking thousand dollars,
pay it on a float at this school and gave you take shift grants.
Like my daughter will literally hold up the school bus because she wanted to
walk slow because she was fat.
So the lady called me was like Miss Pat Everyday I got to wait on Gary Ana to
get on the bus and I've asked her several times to be at the bus stop when I get
there and I said, Ma'am lead that bitch
lever you lead at motherfuckers. She'll get down on time but you know you,
you did. They pepper them in my neighborhood.
I said don't you dare pepper my black ki lead that bitch cause I leave.
You ain't not. You ain't in the car when I get in the cop bitch
bad my kid. No you got to get in the car phone mama cause she'll leave you.
I fuck you [inaudible] school.
I mean my daughter would come in the house one time and say I need you to take
me to stop books. I'm like, what cool kids come to school with Starbucks.
I said, bitch you better go to the school. You better. I said, it's night.
I said, you crazy.
If you think I'm going to get up at six o'clock in the morning,
take you to Starbucks,
you better take your fairs to Starbucks at night and get you a cup and put you
some hot chocolate in the morning. I'm not going,
I'm not getting up at no six o'clock to make you cool. But they do that
status thing. Yes. The standard thing. Come bring me my lunch. I left my life.
I tell my kids if you leave something you didn't fucking want it cause I'm in
the bed with no wig and no broughten yesterday puts it. I'm not getting up
yesterday's post. Yeah. Well how's that work?
Cause I went to bed last night and ain't watched it before.
They called me yesterday pussy. So I'm not getting up you crazy as hell.
I'm not nobody. Nobody gave me nothing.
They understand that no one gave you anything like hell yeah, they get it.
They get it. Yeah, they get it. But they like never. I don't want to hear y'all.
Y'all poor stories. No, listen, that's not true days.
My my cable. Thank you. My cable got cut off one day. Right?
So I go in the House on my cable, cut off, and I tell him I was, I was like,
did you pay the fucking kb hit my hose. Oh my God, I forgot to pay the cable.
Go turn the cable on before the kids get home. I was like, fuck these keys.
You know how many time I had to look at a and TV and thought it was snowing?
I'm not, I'm not going [inaudible] I'm going to bed. Fuck the kids.
I don't care about the kids.
But he broke his neck to pay the cable bill because he don't want the kids to
ever know what it's like to not have light gas on what? Fuck these kids,
they fat. They can miss a couple of meals. Joe, I didn't cut that.
Came back home, but he broke his neck. He came home and it all out. I don't,
I don't go out the way for you. I love you,
but I tell you I don't love you like Jesus do. He loves you on condition.
I was stabbed the shit out of you. I loaned my kids money.
You gotta pay me back. My daughter called me. She said,
can I borrow $3,000 say bitch, you got the wrong number.
3000 you to buy her a car. I don't got nothing to do with that. She,
I got my car, Joe, my car paid off.
I drive a little old last cruel that muckrack [inaudible] crack it. Knees left.
I bought for her. That's what I drive everyday. My Shit paid off.
I'm not buying, you know, call. Well Bitch,
I use all my phone bill for three years. He never paid your phone bill.
So how are you gonna pay me back 3000 now? What did she say to that?
I call you back. I said, I bet
this is my money. I wrote off it is money.
I know you were dealt when I was selling Craig and 40 check,
but you had jaws and nice sheet. I don't know
that your life was hard, but if you had to live it over again,
then what? I mean it made you who you are. [inaudible]. Yeah,
that's what I was going to ask you.
But it's all fucked up thing to ask someone when they tell you they're molested
by your mom's boyfriend and that, you know, you had a,
a baby with this guy when you were 14 and he's married and another one.
And by the time you're 16, you're pregnant with a third. Yeah, no, no. Whatever.
Right. Selling crack and shot in the tet,
no one would ever ask you to live that life again, but you,
you wouldn't change it.
I don't know Joe. I mean it made me who I am, but I always,
I look at life like this. Um, I think I would, you know,
everybody couldn't have dealt with the stuff that I dealt with it.
Like I dealt with it like some people commit suicide completely when people are
always depressed, you know, I kinda feel like I was a chosen one.
God take you through something so it can, you know, to make other people see,
maybe I was poor,
maybe I took burden that everybody else was going through in life and now I was
just chosen one. Then I bring it out and make it funny.
So I'm here to make people let, let people know it's okay. Yeah, it's okay.
It's not about how you start as about how you finish. Right.
I don't dwell on shit. I don't have control over. I can't change the pages.
But Liz left today and I tell people every night on stage when you can laugh
about it, you got control of it.
That's a powerful thing to be able to look at your life like that and just take
ownership. Yeah. You know, like my first kid's father, he hates me.
He fucking hates me. You know why?
Because I'm not the little girl rabbit anymore that he had control of that he
beat any, you know,
I was a little girl searching for love in this whole situation.
I learned to love myself. Joe, you still in touch with him? Yeah. Talk to him.
He be cussing me out. He's like, he's not in jail. Yeah,
that's what I be telling the child. Molest a child molester.
I'm not a [inaudible]. I remember when I needed closure and, um, I was,
I was out here in La and I'm, I'll,
I'm starting to tell these stories about my life and I just wanted him to
apologize for, you know, he shot him in the back of the head, fucking beat me
crazy. So I wanted him to apologize and my hope was like,
why do you need him to apologize? I just want to, he,
I just want to tell you rabbit, I'm sorry. So I call him up and I said, Daryl,
we started talking. Oh Shit. I said his name. Oh, where are you going? Jail.
So I call him and to apologize. And He, I said, I said,
how can you fuck a 12 year old and you grown and you mayor,
you know what he said? He said, your mind and body wasn't 12.
And then she kicked me in my fucking chest,
like a horse and I boohoo and debt day Joe,
I decided I was no longer going to ask him to ask for him to, you know,
to ask me to forgive him. I decided to forgive him. I forgave my momma.
I forgave my mama boyfriend and everybody else that stepped on me and I said,
no longer am I'm ever going to want to come gonna come. I know.
I said from that day on, I'm never gonna ask Y'all for forget.
I'm never going to ask you again. Um,
I decided to forgive you and I that day I forgave him,
my mom and her boyfriend and everybody else that ever violated me because there
was so many other people that I don't still don't talk about, but I forgave him.
That's a very powerful thing and I'm happy and very powerful things.
You can forgive people who've done terrible things to you and you haven't done
shit to them. Yeah. The people that want them to apologize, they chased them,
they checked back the, you're eating yourself up, you eating yourself.
And I was eating myself up cause I just wanted him to say I'm sorry, rabbit.
And he never said it. Well, once he told you that when you were 12, your mind,
your body weren't young. You got to realize you're talking to him.
Fucking idiot. Idiot. And I called my husband and I was crying. He was like,
pat, why you keep, I said, I just want him to ask me too.
I just want him to say he, sorry, this all I want him to say. And he was like,
Pat, why?
And I remember hanging up the phone and I got on my knees and I rarely get on my
knees. Joe and I got vertical. So I don't get [inaudible]
if you know what I'm talking about. So I just asked for forgiveness. I mean,
I forgave him that day. I forgave him and my Mama because of him, my mom and,
and her boyfriend,
John is a three of the people that I hated the most because she didn't protect
me. And when we once tried to tell her that her boyfriend was doing it to us,
you know, he wouldn't listen.
She wouldn't listen because this man was providing,
it was the only time in my life that we didn't get evicted because he was
touching me and my sister. He was always saying, well,
if you tell your Mama y'all gonna get put out, y'all ain't gonna have no food.
So we always thought we was happen. We always thought we was happened.
So you know what? I forgave him and you know they was, they was already dead,
but he's still alive. He's still,
my kid's father is still alive and you wanna know something crazy.
And I never told anybody this. So people, I was like,
why you don't go to your Mama grave site? You know, a lot of people are like,
I don't like fucking with the dead. I figured they want to raise,
leave him the fuck alone. They don't want to hear about the lovely,
the lovely shit. I don't go to her grave y'all,
because that motherfucker put herself next to her.
Wow.
Barrett himself next to my Mama. So I said, fuck both of you.
I'm not going up there. He's laying right next tool.
Wow.
Last time I was there before he died,
I was there cleaning off some ants on top of a gray. And you know, I'm young,
I'm probably,
she died when I was 16 probably 1617 I go out there with a gas can pull it on
top of the light it on fire to get to and be it. I'm going sit home,
carry the ants. You pour gas on it and lit it on fire.
Jesus fucking,
Oh my God, I haven't been back. Jealous.
I haven't been back. No need to go back. I won't go back.
He's next to so he wanted their controls or you got it. Fuck them.
I'm never going back.
God Damn. Ms Pat, everything. Every time I talked to you,
I think I've heard it all.
Oh Shit. Joe, we needed, give me some oligos wine.
I can tell you a hundred another fucking store. What one olive garden there.
God, yes. I love that shit.
I drink a glass a day and I tell you a million fucking stories.
I was telling a story.
I just started writing a bit about how my mama uses was a crap shooter and
propose she shoot the dice.
She would see a lot of four or five kids and she would rub them on our vagina
upon our tee. That was good. Look for her.
She would rub the dice on your vagina probably dies or you pussy for good luck.
[inaudible] you probably fat. Oh my God.
What the fuck?
I don't want to tell the whole story cause I just wrote a beat about it.
So y'all wake up is the fucking bitch. It's fucking hilarious.
You're not going to do it tonight? No, I'm not going to do it at night.
It's not all the way down, but my boy,
when I got my friends like pay you gotta be like I said, I called my brother.
I said both. That's my oldest brother. The biracial. Right?
We say my mom say again, same day, but didn't mother got good hails so we know.
We know that they didn't know Jerry Carolyn. So I say, boy,
you know, do you remember when Mama used to shoot dice? She's like, yeah,
she's rubbing on my motherfucking nose.
Oh
my friends. Like, Oh, you know some shit when black people go like, Whoa, fuck
right.
Oh my God, I can't breathe. Oh. Oh.
Did I fuck up? Oh my God. I'm crying. I can't breathe.
Holy Shit.
God Damn is Pat [inaudible] and then now still laugh.
I love to laugh. I fucking love it. I know you do.
You make people laugh. You want the funniest people I've ever met. Wow.
Thank you Joan. To fact,
fuck what a life you had. God dammit. I been,
it's so hard to listen to as a person who has kids. You know?
It's so hard to think about you being a little girl having to go through that
and you know what? Yeah, it
used to people say, Oh, pay, you should get counseling. But honestly,
comedy has been my counseling because it is a form of counseling for sure.
I was able to share with shit that I had. I was anger about,
I'm no longer angry and making people laugh naked. I'm fucking crying.
I'm literally crying. Yeah.
And you know, then you meet so many people who can have a story like you people.
I was like, oh, ms pet, you're telling my story. Thank you so much.
I had a black lady tell me one time, she was like,
I had my baby at 13 how can you talk about that? I said,
cause bitch I'm happy and my child didn't have the life that I had you so I'm
happy. You know what I only thing I asked for my keys. I see.
I asked you college ain't for everybody so I'm not going to force college on
you, but what you do owe me is a high school diploma and you do owe me to prom
because I didn't have an opportunity to do none of that shit.
So all of them go to the per alum went to the prompt.
I pick that outfit and everyone of them graduated from high school.
You know my daughter was the first one in three generation that graduated high
school in the first one to ever go to college. Then she didn't finish.
But Hey man did my, my youngest daughter just finished criminal justice.
She have associate's degree and you know, every time they do what they like,
I'm going to the prom for you. They graduated high school,
they gave me the high school diploma. My daughter was like, oh,
well I just graduated from college. You hit go your degree.
I was like, Yo Colatti or what? On fucking ears.
You know what I'm talking about? Straight A's. Yes. Melodic. Yeah.
That's what she was. Um, she didn't, she didn't go to her graduation. She's,
she, she didn't want to go on to graduate. So she booked it. She,
she had two options. So she booked it on a day. I was out of town,
but she grew up, she's my first child. I graduated college and I look back,
here I am with an eighth grade education or the GED and I was able to keep my
keys from going on the road that I went down. And you know, most, most,
most kids try to make their parents proud.
I try to make my kids proud to let them know it's not about how you start,
it's about how you finish. You know, I had to,
I had to meet to my oldest daughter and I said,
George Will Front House school and I, you know,
I had to wake her up at one time and I said,
I want to apologize for being such a horrible mom in the beginning,
but I was fucking 14 you know, she was in housing with a, his shoot at it.
She saw me sell drugs in front of her school as that made a lot of fucking
mistakes.
But I'm sorry because I did what everybody else was doing in my community trying
to survive.
And that was one of the hardest thing as a pair because a lot of parents hide,
you know, their past when they kid. But I literally went to my daughter and I,
you know, cause she hated me, Jo. She fucking hated me. She's like,
why do you have to sell drawers in front of my school? I was like,
cause I was here first bitch.
But you know, I think, you know, we have, we have a relationship now,
you know, and then I went off to jail and I missed her going to kindergarten.
And then I grew up in a community where if you was gay,
something was wrong with you. And you know, my daughter, she gets fuck,
he eat everything in Atlanta. She packed man with the Pussy.
So, you know, I had to,
I had to deal with that too because she ran off for awhile when she,
when she wouldn't, you know, when I, she didn't want to tell me she was gay.
Cause I mean I had this thing where if you gave with some roach,
I fucking hated gay women. And I, I used to say this on stage,
when I say white men, when you, when you, when you hate N****s as a good chance,
your white daughter gonna come home with a big Dick Nagle
and open your fucked.
My daughter came home and she was gay and it opened my fucking world to the gay
community. And now like I remember when my daughter came out and somebody,
I was like, you must be ashamed that your daughter's guessed on bitch,
your daughter as a whole.
So your daughter going to take way more dicks than my daughter do.
Then an immediate, I love my daughter,
I love all of my kids and [inaudible] and I told Ashley, that's her name.
I said, it's not about, I had to learn, it's not about your sexuality. Do what?
Make you happy and I will support you to the end as long as you happy because
you saw your daddy stop my face and shoot me and mistreat me.
So if we were to do what makes you happy, just don't do drugs, bitch,
but do what? Make you happy. What, what made you not like gay women before that?
Cause I was raised in the black community. If you was gay, you know,
we're the biggest motherfucker, black people who would throw up a gay child,
I'll tell you something wrong, which we talked to hate, you know,
especially that old school, black community. That's why. So you know people,
you know, I don't know Joe. That's just how we was raised.
The black church drilling in your head, you know, if you gay,
you're going to hell.
And you know what happens with gay people in the black community,
a lot of them leave and never come back back in the day.
A lot of them wait til eight you know, they fucking mental problems.
I don't know. Like I didn't, I don't remember gay uncle anybody.
So, but you know, I know we as a black community, you have to hide.
You had to hide back in those days. So I was taught if he was gay,
it w you was, it was something wrong with you.
And when my daughter came out to be gay,
it opened my fucking world up and I was like,
do I judge my daughter over sexuality or do I love my child because this is my
fucking child. And I remember not seeing her for three years.
She just ran and she had dropped out of college.
She has gone from state to state them, they're homeless.
A lot of them be homeless. And I said, look Ashley. I said,
are you gay? I just want to hear it for myself. She was like, yes Ma'am as well.
Come on home you could eat puts in Atlanta. Yeah
and my child came home
and we built a relationship and I hadn't,
you know I was wrong out cause she heard how I talked about gay people and how
it's almost like when you hear your boy, if you,
if you want to hear your parents, I was N***a, N***a, N***a, N***a, N***a.
Then you want to know wise are you talking about N***a you get curious and you
go outside and like they, it ain't what you think it is.
So when she came out and you know she,
when she came out he opened my world and I'm happy.
I'm happy for my baby and I tell her about my daughter would eat this shit,
are you, she would dick you down. What's Grandpa?
But she happy Joe and this what is all about, you know, all you can ask this,
all I asked is that she get a bitch that treat her right.
That she's a whole rent now. But you know, new girl every six months.
What does new girl she got? She been sticking a little for a long while.
I liked the last girlfriend who you saw bigfoot, but she got rid of big foot,
big foot. If she was a boy, she would play professional baseball.
How big are a few big old beach,
big beach rock? Oh, I was told in Lebron James,
but I liked her alive
girlfriend. She growing on me. So what is all about being happy
all about being happy you, you've, you've done an amazing thing with your life.
Thank you.
You took a terrible beginning and turned it into an amazing present.
You know, you, you're one of the funniest people. I swear to God.
You one of the funniest people I've ever met.
You're a a like a big time professional comedian. People love you. I mean,
I think what you've done is amazing to come where you started from and to be who
you are now. That's, it's amazing.
Thank you. How many, and I tell people all the time, I'm a convicted felon,
then she knows I can do either you laugh or rob, you did not.
But you're great at it. You know,
it's not just that you had a hard life,
you had a hard life and you worked hard to become a great comic.
Well, I had a hard life and I wanted to say my key is in the beginning,
I just didn't want my kids to go through what I went through.
So that was the biggest fire. I was like,
y'all ain't sticking y'all Tom and my babe asshole there.
I'm sorry y'all ain't gonna do that to my children.
Why do you not going to jail? You're not going to drop out. You know? I just,
I just wanted my kids to have shit that I never had,
which was a life, you know? And then, and then, you know,
one thing in my book is about, Ah, I was searching for something.
I wanted a family. I never had a family. I never felt love. Like I feel today,
you know, I got a family. I go home to a husband and see me two times a week,
but he still fucking love me even though he say not at all.
He's being funny. Yeah, he being funny, but I know him love Joe. Yeah, a normal.
I'm not, never had that as a child. I know. I went my I planned vacation.
They'd be like, oh, we got to do that. Fuck Gail. We got to do to do you know,
you want to know what it is to be without a family fucking Mama. We go on,
which we won't. He won't. We don't want to hit these harbor stores. Like
when I book that Disney crew, they was all pissed out,
but they had a fucking ball.
It was 22 of us and we was dead as a family and that's all.
I don't care to go when I go take him to the lake or take him.
I don't care to participate. I just want to know. I just look at them and say,
Oh my God, I get what I fought for my whole fucking life.
Our family to be loved, and I'm loved Joe. That's beautiful.
Then that's all I ever wanted. I don't give a fuck about a fancy call.
I care about a nice weeks, but
listen, you and Junebug, you're going to start this youtube series.
I'm going to workout together, and then the pat down is available on iTunes,
available everywhere. Your book is still out there. It's doing really well.
Yeah. It's called Rabbit Rabbit, right? Nominated for NAACP Image Award,
and we're working tonight, tonight at the comedy store. Thank you. Thank you.
God Damn. That was funny.
[inaudible].